okay today I'm going to talk to you
about physics equations now I've come up
with a technique that should help you to
answer pretty much any equation question
in physics now this may look weird but
this is actually a picture to help us
remember the different stages involved
in doing an equation so obviously Albert
Einstein was the master of equations so
the mnemonic to help remember it is
Albert Einstein's rabbit can see
completely red unicorns now what that
stands for is these different stages
here annotate equation rearrange convert
substitute calculate round and unions if
you follow each of these steps through
then you should be able to answer pretty
much every question in physics to do
with equations so here's an example so
the question says a car accelerates at a
constant rate of 0.001 83 kilometers per
second squared along a flat straight
road the car accelerates from rest for
16 seconds calculate the velocity of the
car after 16 seconds show your answer to
two significant figures so this is a
kind of typical question we get at GCSE
so the very first thing I want you to do
is I want you to think back and I want
you to remember this this is the bit
that you revise to help you remember so
you write down right here Albert
Einstein's rabbit can see completely red
unicorns you literally write this down
because this becomes your checklist so
step one annotate so the first thing
you're going to do is you're going to
annotate this so write that there that
is acceleration isn't it so let me see
16 seconds that's a time so it's asking
you to calculate the velocity so I'm
thinking right what questions got eighty
and V I know the one I know the very
equation that equation is a so now I've
annotated it or ticket my annotate here
with the equation I'm looking for equals
acceleration equals velocity Nova Lassa
T takeaway initial velocity divided by
time whereabouts is my U okay let's go
back well if it's from
first that is actually my initial
velocity isn't it because the beginning
it is not moving at all okay so now I've
done two stages I've annotated it and
I've written down the equation
please remember to write down the
equation because you get a mark for
remembering it okay next up is our I
have to rearrange this so I'm trying to
find the velocity so I need to make V
the subject of the equation so what I do
is I draw two lines down here and I've
got to do the same thing to both sides
of the equation so first of all I want
to get rid of this T so I'm going to
times both sides by T so I now have a T
equals V minus u next up I want to get V
all by itself so I'm going to add you to
each side so now I have a T Plus u
equals V now I'm just going to write
that round the other way just because I
prefer to have the thing I'm looking for
on the left hand side of the equation so
I've done my rearranging I tick that off
notice how I'm using this as a checklist
as I go through my next C convert so
what I need to do is I need to go
through and see the numbers that I've
got and see if they need converting so
this one here is in kilometers per
second squared
I want it in meters per second squared
so to do that I need to times it to get
from kilometers to meters I need to
times it by a thousand so this equals
one point eight three meters per second
squared okay now what's also important
when I'm converting is if I do not need
to convert anything I'm just going to
put a little tick by this to show that
I've actually considered whether it
needs converting or not so that's my
conversion done I tick this off on the
right hand side next up S is for
substitute so now I'm going to
physically put my numbers in so let's
have a look V equals a my value for a is
right here so one point eight three
again I could use this to help me
remember which letters which times
T
tea is here 16 and my initial velocity
well my velocity at rest is going to be
zero because I'm travelling at the zero
meters per second so that is my
substitution another step done next up
what I have to do is I put these numbers
in 1.8 3 times 16 plus 0 so that gives
me twenty nine point two eight always
using calculator even if you think
you're doing your head
to double check your answer so ah I've
now got to the stage where around it now
it's asked me to do the answer to two
significant figures so what I need to do
is I need to look for the two the first
two nonzero values which are here and
here so that's second that nine is that
going to round up or is it going to
round out because that's less than five
it's going to round out so equals twenty
nine so I've now done by rounding and my
final step you is four units now what I
found is a V which is velocity so I've
got to think what are my units for
velocity its meters per second so now I
have done my U as you can see by making
this checklist right here it gives me a
way to easily work through my answers
also even if I get the app final answer
wrong I'm gonna pick up marks along the
way for doing loads of these different
things and showing my working some up to
the examiner so guys just to summarize
please remember Albert Einstein's rabbit
can see completely read unicorns write
these letters down at the beginning of
any physics equation and use it as a
checklist of how to access the question
thank you very much